salut je vais ouvrir cette série sur la
philosophie avec une question
d'actualité puisque je vais interroger
l'expérience du confinement
on entend un peu partout que c'est
l'occasion de faire un bilan de remettre
les choses à plat voire peut-être même
de changer de monde ce serait super
évidemment je ne voudrais pas que la
lure pessimiste que peut prendre le
scepticisme soit en bâtons dans les
roues de ceux qui veulent s'emparer de
cette crise pour changer les choses
bien sûr le vrai problème est systémique
il s'agit de revoir l'organisation
institutionnelle du pouvoir public et la
relation de ce dernier aux puissances
économiques
en somme il faut combattre l'inféodation
de l'état à des logiques néolibérales de
profits avant de peut-être faire une
vidéo qui détaillerait la question du
système
je voudrais me pencher sur ce que le
confinement peut révéler de nos modes
d'existence pour l'analyse politique en
tant que tel je vous renvoie aux gros
boulot fait part aux ont causé aux yeux
certains appellent donc à un travail
d'introspection par exemple bruno latour
récemment dans un blog mediapart a
proposé à la fin de son papier de faire
un petit exercice avec quelques
questions à se poser
ça a le mérite d'interroger
explicitement les liens entre d'une part
nos façons de vivre et d'autre part la
réalité sociale et économique que nos
désirs requiert sa pose donc une
question sous-jacente dans quelle mesure
mes habitudes de vie font-elles le jeu
du système actuel le test de bruno
latour permet d'y répondre de manière
assez concrète
donc je ne reprendrai pas en détail mais
il faudrait faire attention tout de même
à ne pas trop responsabiliser l'individu
on l'a dit ce qui compte c'est de
changer le système de transformer
l'organisation elle même
certains diront mais le système est fait
par les individus bien sûr mais c'est un
peu le flou la poule en l'occurrence
l'organisation ne tombe pas du ciel elle
n'est pas le fait d'un dieu ou d'un seul
dictateur
elle s'est plutôt imposé par du soft
power ce qui suppose qu'on y est un peu
crus ou qu'on avait envie d'y croire
on pourrait imaginer qu'un tel système
se nourrit et encourage des dispositions
mentales préexistantes
l'être humain a des dispositions variées
il faut donc se demander dès qu'elle
cultive et si on veut optimiser
l'organisation politique c'est à dire
que si on veut vraiment changer les
choses sans doute qu'il faut commencer
par s'assurer qu'on s'est débarrassé de
la disposition mentale qui avait ouvert
la porte aux systèmes en premier lieu
lui a offert le gîte et le couvert comme
on dit et lui a permis de s'emparer de
la planète sans cela on prend tout
simplement le risque de recommencer les
mêmes erreurs
alan whiteside jolie formule pour dire
ceci la philosophie de la tyrannie
entraîne et détermine celle de la
rébellion
cette philosophie pour faire court c'est
une approche individualiste conduisant à
croire qu'une personne est libre de se
déterminer elles-mêmes et donc elle
mérite blâmer louanges
selon qu'elles échouent ou réussi ce
qu'elle entreprend la philosophie
contraire c'est celle qui consisterait à
comprendre que la plupart des
comportements sont générés par
l'organisation politique et social dans
lesquels ces comportements voit le jour
c'est la proche qui consiste à affirmer
que le succès d'un individu et le succès
de la société à laquelle il appartient
et par conséquent que l'échec d'un
individu est également l'échec de la
société qui l'a fait naître
il n'y a pas d'un côté les gens bien
qu'il faudrait remercier ou admirer et
de l'autre les méchants ou parasites
qu'il faudrait stigmatiser ou condamné
une société vraiment libéré des
soubassements idéologiques du système
individualiste est une société qui
virait chaque individu parasites comme
le symptôme de ses propres échecs et
donc comme l' indice de la modification
à apporter au système
je tiens à dire rapidement et il faudra
sûrement faire une vidéo plus détaillée
là dessus que l'état actuel de la
science tend plutôt à confirmer cette
lecture l'animal humain et malléable est
largement déterminé par son
environnement
il apparaît donc normal d'en tirer les
conséquences politiques pour ceux que ça
intéresse et qui pour une raison ou une
autre en douteraient encore aller voir
par exemple expérience de benjamin libé
en neurosciences de seulement agents
psychologie le livre free wheels de sam
harris ou la psychologie évolutionnaire
en ce sens même le plus sincère des
révolutionnaires anti capitaliste risque
de reconduire les logiques du système
qu'il combat sylvie son militantisme
comme une histoire dont il serait le
protagoniste héroïque affrontant des
méchants en parlant d'histoire justement
je voulais convoqué alasdair mcintyre un
philosophe écossais dans les travaux et
tic ont mis l'accent sur une dimension
de l'existence humaine
la narration ainsi selon lui l'homme est
un animal narratif pour répondre à la
question
dois-je faire je dois répondre d'abord à
la question à quelle histoire ou à
quelle histoire
suis-je liés nous développons notre
rapport au monde à travers des histoires
que ce soit celle de nos proches ou
d'inconnus la relation à soi est
également marqué par cette approche
narrative
cela tient en partie au fait que nous
nous fixons des buts ce qu'aristote
appelé le telos où cos finale ce en vue
de quoi nous agissons ce but défini
notre quête le trajet qui nous rapproche
ou nous éloigne de l'objet de cette
quête est ce qu'on peut appeler un arc
narratif pour reprendre le vocabulaire
des scénaristes il peut bien sûr y avoir
des arcs narratifs à l'intérieur d'arc
plus important par exemple pour luke
skywalker l'arc principal c'est de
battre lempire à l'intérieur de cet arc
il y à l'arc qui correspond au fait
d'aller sur dagobah pour trouver yoda et
s'entraîner et pour en solo ça consiste
à pécho la princesse nous expérimentons
notre vie comme l'ensemble de ces arcs
narratifs
par exemple il y à l'arc narratif de la
carrière professionnelle à l'intérieur
duquel il y à l'arc qui consiste à
choisir les études qu'on va suivre
prendre cette décision revient pour mc
intyre à se demander quel métier
correspond le mieux à notre personnage
plus ou moins consciemment on se regarde
et on se dit quelque chose comme je ne
suis pas le genre de personne à faire
des études de commerce ce qui me
correspond
ce qui est logique compte tenu du
personnage que je suis depuis que je
suis petit c'est à dire un garçon qui
aime lire écrire qui est bon en français
est nul en bio par exemple c'est de
faire des études littéraires et cela
dessinent un horizon plus ou moins
lointain si je me construis a vraiment
comme littéraire peut-être que mes
études de lettres
c'est la première étape d'un arc
narratif qui va me conduire à
l'enseignement à l'université au fait de
publier des livres etc
il y à aussi l'arc de la vie
sentimentale est ce que je m'imagine est
un homme célibataire ou marié que des
enfants
on peut aussi penser l'arc géographique
dans quelle région du monde en ville ou
à la campagne me vois je livre répondre
à cette question c'est avoir une idée du
type de personnage qu'on aime ou qu'on
veut être et donc du genre de péripétie
qu'on projette de vivre
on pourrait croire que c'est une simple
question de préférence personnelle mais
c'est sans doute plus compliqué que ça
spinoza à tuer le game quand il a
procédé à sa célèbre inversion de la
relation entre le désir et le jugement
nous ne désirons pas une chose parce que
nous la jugeons bonne mais nous la
jugeons bonne parce que nous le désirons
sans doute désirons-nous tout un tas de
choses
à cause de l'histoire que nous désirons
vivre et du personnage que nous désirons
incarner mais non seulement nous ne
sommes pas maîtres de nos désirs mais en
plus nous en sommes rarement conscient
c'est pour cela qu'il est judicieux de
se demander quel personnage je suis dans
quel genre d'histoire suis-je embarqué
chaque décision importante que nous
prenons révèle donc en creux la quête
que nous choisissons est un peu comme
dans un jeu de rôle
cette quête est intimement associé au
personnage on peut choisir le combo
businessman richesse comédienne
célébrités scientifique connaissances
politiques pouvoir ou humanitaire
altruisme évidemment nous ne vivons pas
seul notre histoire est entremêlé à
celle des autres et donc une question
super important de se pose est-ce que je
me vis comme le personnage principal
pour certains oui c'est évident ils
diront
la preuve quand je meurs mon histoire
s'arrête et pour d'autres pas du tout ce
qui compte avant tout c'est la
communauté dont on fait partie on joue
un rôle dans une histoire collective que
ce soit la famille les amis
une communauté sociale une entreprise
pour certains voire une nation on
pourrait être tenté de formuler une
hypothèse prudente le monde tel qu'on
connaît favorise les idéologies qui
pousse à se concevoir comme personnage
principal comme le centre du monde une
chose fascinante que ça interroge c'est
notre capacité ou incapacité à décentrer
notre point de vue a adopté des
perspectives différentes ou au moins à
reconnaître et intégrée l'existence de
points de vue différents
nous sommes sans doute tous capable
d'attribuer des états mentaux à autrui
mais il s'agit déjà de savoir si on fait
un peu ou beaucoup
et en plus si on ne s'autorise pas un
peu trop à projeter notre imaginaire
propre sur autrui à faire comme si on
savait déjà tout de lui
cela renvoie à ce qu'on appelle le
perspectives techniques
la capacité à se mettre à la place
d'autrui et à simuler son expérience on
en est tous capables mais on ne fait pas
tous autant ni tous de la même manière
il est tentant de combiner ça avec l'
approche narrative
quelle place ma narration fait-elle aux
autres points de vue possibles
ma narration se limitait lama
perspectives ou pour le demander
autrement à quel point suis enfermé dans
la perspective de ma petite histoire
personnelle jeudi en fermer parce que
c'est un peu le paradoxe d'une société
qui encourage les gens à s'occuper des
mêmes pour mieux vivre alors que ça
risque fortement de provoquer le
contraire à savoir une forme
d'aliénation à soi même à ses désirs et
à son art 6 6 me je vais faire une vidéo
plus précisément là dessus une manière
de répondre à cette question ce serait
de se demander dans quelle mesure les
histoires des autres sont réduites à des
moyens pour mon histoire à moi est ce
que je vois l'arc narratif d'autrui
comme une fin en soi comme une quête
tout aussi importante pour moi que la
mienne ou est ce que je vois son
histoire comme un élément de décor comme
le trajet d'un pnj un personnage non
joueur avec qui je peut interagir pour
que mac est à moi soit plus riches et
donc pour en revenir au confinement
je crois que celui ci nous permet
justement de regarder un peu
différemment notre rapports narratifs à
la vie cette expérience nous permet de
répondre à cette question quel rôle
autrui joue-t-il dans mon histoire
parenthèse je garde à l'esprit que tout
le monde ne vit pas le confinement dans
les mêmes conditions
seul à deux ou à plusieurs avec des gens
qu'on aime plus ou moins en travaillant
ou non en ville ou à la campagne dans un
petit espace où un grand ces questions
sont donc des éclairages trop
schématique pour faire écho à toutes les
situations individuelles
néanmoins en faisant un petit effort
d'imagination
cela devrait tout de même nous permettre
de réfléchir un peu peut-être que
certains manque d'activités concrètes du
sport sortir dans des bars faire du
shopping aller à des concerts et pour
chaque activité on peut se demander le
rôle qu'elle joue dans le système
économique
c'est une des fonctions du questionnaire
de la tour peut-être que certains diront
tout simplement que ce qui leur manque
c'est le contact humain est alors oui
bien sûr mais quoi dans le contact
humain
personnellement depuis le début du
confinement
j'enseigne à distance eh bien ça met en
lumière certaines dimensions mon métier
par exemple une chose qui me manque
c'est de pouvoir regarder dans les yeux
mais étudiants pour sentir si les ont
compris ça c'est un manque dont on
pourrait dire qu'il est lié à une part
essentielle de mon métier
en revanche si le fait d'enseigner c'est
à dire de parler devant un auditoire qui
m'écoutent plus ou moins attentivement
est pour moi quelque chose de narcisse 6
ans comme on dit en psychologie
c'est à dire un moyen d'obtenir une
image de moi même un miroir social qui
détermine la représentation que je me
fais de ma propre personne alors je vais
ressentir un manque spécifique différent
de la simple difficultés à exécuter mon
travail de manière optimale
ce manque pourrait donc être révélateur
du rôle extra-professionnelles que joue
mon métier dans la vie
dans ce cas les étudiants sont un moyen
pour moi de mai mais moi même en quelque
sorte
il ya là une manière de distinguer
différents niveaux de complexité dans
l'instrumentalisation qu'on fait
d'autrui pour prendre un autre exemple
peut-être que ma petite amie me manque
parce qu'entre autre chose j'aime sentir
son amour pour moi c'est un niveau assez
simple mais si ce qui me manque dans
l'absence de ma petite amie
c'est ce regard admirateur qu'elle peut
avoir et qui me donne l'impression
d'être moins bête parce que je manque
habituellement de confiance en moi alors
c'est une instrumentalisation plus
complexe
c'est une des questions que je posais
ici à quel point notre rapport à autrui
et ils intriguent et à des valeurs
symboliques complexe donc déjà se
demander est ce que je fait consciemment
attention au point de vue d'autrui
est ce que je prend effectivement la
peine de simuler son point de vue il ya
sûrement des gens qui ne prennent
presque jamais en compte la possibilité
d'une autre perspective que la leur mais
au delà de ces cas explicitement
problématique
peut-être que nous nous ne le faisons
pas assez et on se demande ensuite quel
genre d'information la simulation du
point de vue d'autrui me procure tél je
peux tirer de cette simulation des
informations sur autrui sur le monde en
général ou sur moi même
et quant aux informations qui me
concerne ceux demandés sont elles une
manière pour moi de m'assurer que je
suis quelqu'un de bien pour les autres
c'est à dire un bon voisin un bon père
un bon citoyen ou un pont profs ou
sont-elles une manière pour moi de
m'assurer que je suis quelqu'un de bien
pour moi même c'est à dire que l'idée de
moi me plaît que j'aime mon identité
bien sûr ces deux dimensions peuvent se
mêler l'une à l'autre
on peut aimer l'idée de soi comme être
altruiste toujours est il que cela ne
suppose pas la même relation à soi ni la
même relation à l'autre
c'est à dire qu'il s'agit d'interroger
la place que prend la préoccupation de
soi l'enjeu de mon identité dans mon
rapport aux autres il s'agit donc aussi
de questionner la relation que nous
avons aux informations dans quelle
mesure notre expérience est elle
déterminée par les idées qu'on peut en
dégager
je pars du principe qu'à voir la
question à l'esprit c'est déjà la
première étape d'une investigation qui
peut mener ensuite à une prise de
conscience et pour enrichir cette
enquête
je vous encourage vivement à regarder la
vidéo sur les niveaux de complexité
affective c'est en quelque sorte la
suite de ce que nous venons de voir
merci